on parle à présent de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne elle se
poursuit avec ses nouvelles cibles côté
son apprent ce matin que les régions de
course qui est de Belgorod ont été
attaqués tôt aujourd'hui par les forces
ukrainiennes opération en cours aussi
toujours dans l'est de l'Ukraine une
formation heureuse de à Macif Kaya ville
occupé était prise pour cible où on
déplore là-bas un mort et 36 blessés keV
qui concentre également ses efforts sur
zapporodia vous le savez et ça centrale
l'Ukraine accuse d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
Moscou de préparer là-bas une
provocation dans un avenir proche
propose d'écouter le président Paulo
divers zenenski
nos services de renseignement nous
informent que l'armée russe a placé des
objets semblables à des explosifs sur le
toit de plusieurs unités de la centrale
nucléaire de zaporigia il est probable
qu'elle en ait besoin pour simuler une
attaque contre la centrale il pourrait
aussi y avoir un autre type de scénario
quoi qu'il en soit le monde voit et ne
peut t'éviter de voir que la seule
source de danger pour la centrale
nucléaire de zaporigia et la Russie et
personne d'autre